in berlin says its assessment that
alexey navalny was poisoned with a
chemical nerve agent from the novichok
group has been confirmed by
labs in france and sweden earlier a
german military lab
found traces of the poison in the
russian opposition figures biosamples
uh russia's request to get access to
that evidence has so far then
gone unheeded still peter oliver can
bring some speed on this our europe
correspondent in berlin hi gem pete knew
in then
what exactly have we heard from the
german side to
paint small for us
well berlin is now saying that three
laboratories have confirmed that
novichok or a substance from the
novichok family was present in samples
taken
from alexa navalny we've also heard that
the organization for the prohibition of
chemical weapons
is starting its process to verify
uh those those results that have been
taken we heard from stefan zeibert on
monday he's the german government
spokesperson
basically the voice of angela merkel and
he said that laboratories
in france and in sweden had now
confirmed the presence of novichok
in those samples taken from mr navalny
clarification on the navalny case the
federal government has involved the opcw
in the analysis of evidence in addition
two other
international laboratories have
confirmed that a nerve agent from the
novichok group was the cause of the
poisoning
well as that information comes in the
we're also getting news from over in
russia
in the city of omps where alexei navalny
was first treated
from the senior toxicologist at the
hospital where he was first treated
saying that alexei navalny did not
present
to them when he first arrived with
symptoms that would be
well symptoms you would see from
somebody who had been poisoned with
novichok with a novichok nerve agent
it's hard to see how this news coming
out of berlin on monday will placate
russia moscow has said it wants to see
the data
that germany has it's now shared that
data it would seem with laboratories in
sweden and in france and with the opcw
moscow is saying it needs to see that
evidence
this whole incident cannot but raise
questions
about some foul play being staged
we hear what statements followed and
what measures are being mentioned
discussed or involved this lead us leads
us to an unavoidable
rhetorical question latency posed in
such
uh situations we wanna eat facet
uh protest who is to benefit from this
the one that one did it if you demand
explanations
put the facts on the table and we'll
compare notes
why should we trust allegations
uncollaborated
by evidence even this is as you say
beyond
reasonable doubt
well foreign minister of russia sergey
lavrov has said that
russia will watch keenly to see if
there's any sanctions imposed from the
west we're expecting on tuesday
that the european parliament will hold a
special plenary session
in which the alexa navalny case will be
discussed
if any sanctions are forthcoming from
then
sergey lavrov says that russia will
respond
um accordingly and um well
in unison with what is imposed upon them
now alexa navalny's been here in berlin
for just over three weeks now last week
he was taken out of a coma
that medics had induced in him he was
put into that coma specifically
doctors say that he is recovering but
say there could be a long road ahead
for him medically peter thank you for
the update peter oliver europe
correspondent
you